may you serve the institute with all the
skill wisdom dedication is tremendously
prepared for this job he knows MIT
inside and help he is a community
builder he empowers and energizes and
get so much of the community trying new
things
I think it's awesome that he was already
championing MITx when he was the provost
and so I think as we go forward at X and
get a lot of attention I'm really
excited about that
the MIT I know loves challenges the MIT
I know solve the unsolvable shapes the
future and served our nation and the
world the MIT I know and love does not
stand on the sidelines one community
together in service missions back into a
user interface this is actually our
prototype a big part of this week's
events are these three symposia and I
think there are a critical part because
they do showcase elements of MIT but
they also have begun dialogue as we look
forward I'll spend some time talking
about how online learning is borrowing
from gaming technologies there's this
giant quilt it is MIT and there are so
many different beautiful patches there
that are being built even as we speak
and some have been around for a long
time mit has and still does shape
amazing individuals that see the entire
world as their playground ladies and
gentlemen the 17th president of the
Massachusetts Institute raphael ripe is
well known to us at Harvard for his
insight and his judgment he is a
generous and genuine convener who
listens as much as he speaks
we like the rhythm of his name Rafael
rife thus you are about to hear a rumba
for Rafael rife society continues to
need what the residential research
university does better than any other
institution incubate brilliant young
talent and create the new knowledge and
innovation that fuel our society I will
need MIT to continue to make significant
contributions in the area of race and
diversity equity and inclusion we have
many compelling suggestions for
practical change this include better
ways to search for and mentor new talent
and to improve the orientation process
for new members of our community we're
able to reach out to a lot of people
have a run on campus we're like
promoting a lot of ideals here obviously
like health and fitness have to have
humanity general community wellness and
like community joining together and of
course like celebrate our new president
ready
around the dome campus quest is a campus
wide scavenger hunt all the groups just
go through and see how many of the
challenges they can complete whoa things
like the LED light up challenge the
origami challenge and then we had a
bungee run it's a really great reminded
that we have such a strong community
here and that the culture is really
important to everyone and now despite
silently suffering torment and
humiliation these many years as the
victim of em I t's creative hackers John
Harvard has dressed himself up for
today's occasion president rife on
behalf of the red brick school up the
street I present a symbol of our lasting
friendship
we had an auger a shin reception
luncheon for our 17th president dr.
Raphael rife today thank you me too you
think of it and it was for all of the
support staff here he wanted to meet all
of the support staff you're very nice
it's absolutely player to be recognized
and to see president it was very nice
that he could make it took his time and
came and said thank you to us it was
very special forget procrastination the
train has left the station
he's got a new equation to offer to the
nation we are all in this great
enterprise together we have a great deal
to accomplish and the world is waiting
so let's get started